[Música]
hola como pueden ver soy una joven líder
de la comunidad baile ubicado al oriente
de colombia
tuzzio que significa banco banco de
madera gruesa
que se utilizan
para sentarse
soy una joven que gracias a su familia y
a sus comunidades puede contar con una
carrera universitaria
a diferencia de muchos de los que hacen
parte de mi comunidad ya sea por falta
de recursos o la oportunidad no tienen
la misma dicha
soy una joven que le gusta soñar le
gusta vivir y le gusta dejar volar su
mente gracias a la crianza que le dio su
familia
una joven que busca y es ambiciosa con
el bienestar de su comunidad
gracias a todo eso hoy quiero invitarlos
a que dejen volar su mente
a que vayamos
a lugares imaginarios como el que yo les
voy a describir
imaginen
que están en una tierra
super extensas que viven en un ranchito
que está hecho de barro
que no cuentan con luz
que no cuentan con gas
que el agua es insuficiente
imaginen
todo esto todos estos problemas o estos
inconvenientes que les estoy diciendo
muchas personas viven su día a día
con esta necesidad
imaginen que a medida que van creciendo
se van dando cuenta de las problemáticas
que hay a nivel mundial
y la contaminación ambiental el cambio
climático
que no dejan que esas tierras en las que
nosotros vivimos
y deje de sembrar o criar animales
imaginen que vienen personajes de legos
que te convencen y te dan
esas herramientas y esos elementos para
que puedan hacer de esas extensas
tierras de donde viven
una herramienta de trabajo
trabajo
que lo hacen tus padres tus abuelos sus
tíos los hermanos
y baile
en esas 10 extensas tierras
quieren cultivar
pero como se preguntarán por qué el agua
es insuficiente
en vez de sentarnos a lamentar
busquemos soluciones
soluciones como iguales
soluciones
y que podamos con la que podamos cuidar
el medio ambiente como reciclando como
cuidando el agua
cosas que también nos benefician
nosotros porque el agua de donde vivimos
es escasa pero también queremos seguir
adelante
también queremos surgir
entonces imaginen que hay una reunión
donde están todos los miembros de tu
familia
alguien se lo ocurre y dice pero si
nosotros tenemos
y la capacidad
gracias a esas personas que nos han
hecho entender que esto puede ser un
beneficio para nosotros
entonces
busquemos
potes que se usan cotidianamente en
cualquier parte en cualquier parte
botellas de agua de gaseosa o de
cualquier otra cantidad de cosas
agarremos la tapa y sutilmente hacemos
un ligero hueco
tenemos el bote de agua luego de llenar
el bote de agua le colocamos la taza y
colocamos en la siembra
y la colocamos con la tapa hacia abajo
para que el agua sutilmente pueda bajar
por la tapa en el huequito que hicimos y
pueda mantener la tierra húmeda para que
nuestro fruto nuestra siembra puedan
cosechar puedan surgir
imaginé que a medida del tiempo que va
pasando
todos esos frutos que en algún momento
cosechamos están surgiendo ya están
dando frutos esas plantas que cosechamos
a medida de todo esto
suele pasar
que muchas veces solamente nos
imaginamos vos
que solamente soñamos
que solamente dejamos volar nuestra
mente para ver
como se puede ver
pero qué pasa si todo eso que imaginamos
lo podemos volver lo podemos convertir
en una realidad
así sucedió en mi comunidad
nosotros como personas
que no tenemos
no tenemos cómo ir o cómo mandar a
nuestros niños a una escuela
porque solamente es un ranchito
hecho de barro
que solamente poder podemos mandarlo con
un cuaderno y un lápiz porque no se
puede contar para más
niños y personas que viven dentro de la
comunidad que solamente podemos comer
una o dos veces al día porque el dinero
en el caso
esa persona
como puede como pueden surgir si
realmente no aprenden las condiciones
necesarios pero realmente imaginen que
eso no lo pueden dejar morir porque
porque nosotros debemos surgir nosotros
debemos seguir adelante nosotros debemos
velar por nuestra comunidad
cierto entonces qué pasa que nosotros
queremos que estos niños
sean grandes sean unos niños de bien
unos niños estudioso y que así con todo
eso puedan velar por nuestra comunidad
hoy en día
contamos con una huerta
que da frutos como la acompaña la
patilla
la verdura como
la olla na
da granos como el frijol
entre otras cosas también da dalt de
alimentos como la yuca el maíz
que son comidas tradicionales de
nosotros
como la berenjena
entonces
y todo eso que realmente en algún
momento soñamos hoy se ha convertido en
una realidad
realidad que gracias a esas personas que
vinieron desde lejos con su inspiración
y con su necesidad de ayudar
hoy
queremos
y comercializar nuestros productos al
mercado exportarlo porque no
y así es el ranchito en que nuestros
niños van a la escuela se puede
convertir en una escuela digna de niños
que quieren surgir y que quieren seguir
adelante
niño
que puedan velar por nuestra cultura que
puedan velar por nuestra comunidad
entonces
queremos
que si nosotros
lo pudimos soñar nosotros no lo pudimos
hacer
porque otras personas que viven
alrededor de nosotros no lo pueden hacer
hoy quería compartirle esta historia
para que se dieran cuenta
que el hecho que muchas veces no
tengamos los recursos que el hecho que
muchas veces contemos con tantas
necesidades también se puede porque si
lo podemos creer si lo podemos soñar
también lo podemos hacer
gracias
[Música]